[Music]
good morning to you it's seven o'clock
you're watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster now the united
states will today attempt to reassert
its role
as a global leader on climate change
with president biden set to host global
leaders
at a virtual summit at the white house
his administration says the world
is way behind schedule in tackling the
issue in a moment
i'll ask the business and energy
secretary kwasik
what the uk is doing to catch up
now also this morning a historic verdict
but how much is it going to change in
america
after the conviction of derek chauvin
i'll talk to a u.s police veteran who
pushed for reforms over a 28-year career
that's at half past seven and
walking 30 miles per way we'll hear from
this amazing three-year-old girl
who's powering on with a prosthetic leg
to walk a mile a day
to raise money for a children's hospital
that's at 8 45.
it is thursday the 22nd of april a
global call to action
president biden will convene world
leaders at a climate summit today
and make key pledges to cut emissions in
the united states
one of the key witnesses whose testimony
led to the conviction of derek shoving
tells sky news
systemic change is needed in america
he gets a nice good trial and he gets to
be
protected in prison for however long but
obviously that's not the same for an
african american
india records more than 300 000 covid
cases
in a day the largest daily total seen
anywhere in the world
[Music]
and hope for live events more on the
trial that we'll see
4 000 music fans attend the brit awards
without social distancing or masks
it's a chilly start but there is so much
sunshine around
how long will it last all the weather
details coming up shortly
a very good morning to you president
biden will lead calls for more global
action on climate change today when he
hosts 40 world leaders at a virtual
summit at the white house
he's also expected to set an example to
the world by promising to cut
greenhouse gas emissions in the united
states by at least
half by the end of the decade the pledge
and the summit represent a concerted us
effort to reclaim
credibility and leadership on climate
change
after four years of inaction under
donald trump
alex rossi reports now from michigan on
whether the u.s
will be able to embrace a greener future
there is smoke noise
and plenty of fumes this amateur race
meet in michigan
is an american love letter to the petrol
engine
but if president joe biden's to convince
the country to ditch the gas guzzlers
and go electric
he has his work cut out
so much fun with what you can do with
gas engine you'd never buy an electric
car
i highly doubt it we're in the middle of
american car culture
so it would take a lot for them to
give up the cars they have especially
fun cars like this
there is some hope for the green push in
the crowd of races
we spotted one electric car owner
ben olson made the conversion not to
save the planet
but for performance you got to bring him
in the car you got a floor and you got
to show them how fast it really is
at the end of the day most people are
not going to go um
and adapt to the future technology until
they experience it
pollution from cars is the number one
source of emissions
and america will need to be weaned off
its addiction to petroleum cars
if it's to hit its climate target of net
zero
by 2050 for joe biden to achieve his
green agenda
it's going to be an enormous challenge
at the moment
only around two percent of new cars
heading out onto america's roads are
electric
but for success that number's gonna have
to go up
significantly but many consumers are put
off by the cost
the lack of range and there are simply
not enough charging points
there is also another challenge and
that's making sure
american workers are taken along for the
ride
in detroit abandoned car factories
litter the skyline
the fear is the green revolution will
cost
jobs people are going to have to believe
that this green agenda
means them too right now many people
think that that means someone else that
means someone with a college degree
that means someone who has a doctorate
in something they don't think that that
applies
to a person that working on the factory
line
one of joe biden's first acts as
president was to rejoin the paris accord
his new green deal he says will
eventually boost the economy
and in california you can get a glimpse
already of that shiny new
future this state is home of the
electric car
but for it to go mainstream the consumer
will need to be front
and center it's important for the car
industry
and for technology to step up and make
the the
product and the experience of driving an
electric vehicle
more attractive the environment is now
central to
all major policy decisions for the u.s
government
as it tries to make its economy green
[Applause]
but it's clear there is still a long
road ahead
convincing the public to embrace an
electric
future alex rossi sky news michigan
well amongst the leaders speaking at the
climate summit is prime minister boris
johnson as well as china xi jinping
his first meeting with president biden
since the advent
of the new u.s administration so let's
have a quick look at
what pledges the different countries may
actually make today
and it's expected president biden will
announce at least a 50
cut in greenhouse gas emissions by 2030.
that's ambitious
that comes after the uk pledged to
reduce emissions by
78 by 2035 that's from 1990 levels
some major polluters less ambitious in
december china said its emissions would
peak in 2030
and that it was aiming for net zero
emissions by 2060
10 years later than many other nations
and india excuse me the third worst
greenhouse gas emitter in the world has
criticized long-term emission reduction
targets
with their minister for power calling
them pie
in the sky
well let's talk to the business and
energy secretary quasi quarten good to
see you
this morning look the prime minister
clearly wants to say that that the uk is
leading the way with this hugely
ambitious 78
reduction target by 2035
what have you worked out as to how we
actually make that work
i think there are lots of things that
we're doing that are actually
uh giving us a good chance of getting
there if you look at that 1990
base uh date that's where all these
emissions reductions are calculated from
already today we've reduced emissions by
45 percent
uh and what we're saying is that we will
reduce uh further reducing by
to 78 to 2035 and if you look at the
things we've done
we've done things like taking coal off
the power grid even only
eight years ago something like uh forty
percent of our electricity
was coming from uh coal fired uh power
stations
today that figure is two percent so
we've taken out
uh coal from electricity generation uh
we're relying more on offshore wind
we've got solar power and there are lots
of things
that we're doing which means that i
think the target is very much achievable
it's not easy
no one is suggesting that it's an easy
uh target to reach
but if we do uh continue decarbonization
we your
clip showed uh the roll out of electric
vehicles
uh there were challenges but there's
increasing demand for electric vehicles
uh and uh it's very possible very likely
i think
uh that we can actually reach the target
well what do you say to those
businesses who who've got concerns that
you know you just can't grow the economy
it quit
at least as as quickly as as before
whilst trying to meet such ambitious
targets
i don't think that's right i mean if you
look at what's happened since 1990
uh which is the as i said the base state
from which these reductions are
calculated
we've managed to grow uh the economy by
80
in that time and yet we've also reduced
our carbon emissions by 45
so it's not true to say that uh reducing
uh carbon emissions uh can will impair
economic growth
i think on the contrary i think a lot of
the jobs that we're creating a lot of
the investment that's coming into this
country
that i see as business secretary is very
much focused
on trying to drive the green agenda
people are wanting to invest
in hydrogen production they're wanting
to invest in offshore wind
but but we are now because of brexit you
know in a
in a global economy in a much more sort
of direct way and we have now got to
compete directly with
with places like china and india that
you know are
carbon-heavy economies i think they are
but even they
are changing their behavior i mean it
was interesting in your clip where you
said that
china would try and reach net zero by
2060. they only announced that in
october
um i mean when i came into the
department two years ago
people said to me well there's no way
that you're ever going to get the
chinese to commit to
net zero carbon emissions well uh
they've very publicly
stated that that's what they want to see
and
the evidence suggests that they are
bringing in policies to try and reduce
carbon emissions and they're very
interested in producing batteries and
also trying to drive decarbonization
we know that the the sort of uk carbon
budget if we can use those terms
is now including aviation emissions for
the first time
we know that heathrow is the biggest
emitter of of greenhouse gases in the uk
so with these very ambitious new targets
where does that leave heathrow expansion
i think he threw and i speak to um
business leaders
uh at heathrow all the time it happens
to be very near
my constituency they're very committed
to this agenda they're very committed to
what we call jet zeros so that's the
idea of having sustainable
aviation fuel there's a lot of research
going into this area uh heathrow is very
committed
uh to trying to get sustainable fuels
and they see it as a challenge
but that's something that they can they
can meet over the next few years
and i think that as i've said you can
grow the economy and reduce carbon
emissions i think we can
try and get to a world where we have uh
sustainable aviation
and that will drive economic growth as
well so i don't see a contradiction
between trying to reduce carbon
emissions
and trying to grow the economy uh
minister can we talk
access and particularly access to to
number 10. now the prime minister
yesterday
um said no you know he was not going to
make any apology
um over the dyson issue because he said
it was all related to
the ventilator project so no apology uh
needed because he was
you know it was all about the the
emergency uh
sort of uh production of ventilators but
doesn't it seem inherently unfair
that some people particularly bigger
businesses but some people
have direct access to the prime minister
whereas others don't
i don't i don't think it's unfair in the
sense that people are trying to lobby
uh ministers uh lobby mps all the time
um and in this particular instance i
think we're trying to
create a story where there isn't one uh
the prime minister was very clear
yesterday that he would have done
exactly the same thing again he had a
duty as far as he was concerned
to make sure that we got ventilators
made here in the uk
at the time as you'll remember simon
there was a huge crisis in italy
precisely because uh they hadn't uh
produced
enough ventilators and that was the
thing that we had to do
and he moved in his words the prime
minister said
he moved heaven and earth to try and
make sure that we got ventilators
made here in the uk and that's what
happened it averted
an even greater crisis and it saved
lives and it was very interesting to me
that
tony blair uh just said yesterday
that he would have essentially done the
same thing he didn't see uh
an issue there and as i understand it uh
one of the labour
shadow ministers also said that kiersten
would have done the same thing they
would have
tried their hardest to try and get
ventilators
made here in the uk yes but that's
that's one
separate issue isn't it one particular
issue
but the id the idea that people can
contact the prime minister
directly i mean it's reported in the
times today that boris johnson
was warned by civil servants to
to change his number because they
thought he was too easily accessible
um i think that uh in the real
world in reality uh people are
contacting ministers
contacting mps all the time business
people
are contacting mps all the time
constituents also
contact me on my phone and i think that
in the modern democracy it's very good
that people actually have direct
can have direct access uh to ministers
and people who are taking responsibility
in this particular instance i don't
think they're separated i think it's
very
important to realize that we were acting
in unprecedented circumstances
prime minister had to make decisions at
very high speed um
and there was a crisis people were dying
of this
disease and we needed to make
ventilators and he he
in his words he said he moved heaven and
earth to make sure that the ventilators
were made
here we didn't have a shortage i think
it was what he did was
uh very responsible but but this does
raise the specter of distrust
in government i mean you defend it
that's that's your position
to do so but you know johnny mercer now
former defense minister has talked about
you know government being a dis
disrespectful
distrustful cesspit now that's that's
coming from
from one of your own you know i mean
johnny
i just wanted to say i mean johnny is a
great colleague he's a good friend of
mine
a very passionate advocate for veterans
rights and their causes and i i
wish him all the best um i don't really
recognize
uh his description of government i think
there are frustrations in any work
environment there are frustrations and
people feel uh sometimes they can't
uh get through to to what they actually
want to do i mean that happens in in all
walks of life
um and i know that uh johnny was a was a
great minister and i wish him the best
yeah but i mean when you when you look
at the quote
you know this is the most distrustful
awful environment i've ever worked in in
government
almost nobody tells the truth is what
i've worked out
and i don't think anyone can get on
their high horse about trust and ethics
and all the rest of it in politics
because as far as i'm concerned
most of it is a bit of a cesspit i mean
you you cannot
get a more damning indictment
of what is going on well in politics but
from his perspective directly in
government
johnny has uh his own issues uh relating
to
uh what he feels about the government i
think he was uh very frustrated
around the uh particular issues relating
to veterans
and i think he'd probably be best to
direct those questions uh to johnny i
think he was a very good
minister he was a very good colleague i
don't recognize his description
of government i accept that there are
frustrations
uh within government but that happens in
in lots of different
walks of life people feel frustrated in
their jobs
sometimes they can't uh get quite get
what they wanted to
but forgive me for interrupting but his
argument seems to be pretty much that
you know he
he effectively told untruths to the
people he was trying to represent
because
he was you know he was he was told
something would be acted on
and then it wasn't so it's it's that
lack of trust it's broken promises in
effect
i'm not here to uh you know criticize
what johnny did
or to have an argument with him i mean
if that he had specific
uh concerns that which he's raised i'm
sure
that you've asked him uh questions about
that
for my part i don't recognize his
description of government
uh and i don't uh i don't accept that
description that's not what
i've experienced but if that's what he
said i suspect um
you'd better off uh ask you'd be better
off asking him about
his own opinions my own perspective is
that yeah there are frustrations
in government sometimes things can be a
little slow
but generally people work in a very
collegial way
as i've said i've always worked very
well with johnny uh he's always been a
good friend
a parliamentary colleague um and i wish
him the best
minister good to talk to you thank you
well our political correspondent kate
mccann was listening to that kate
i think it's fascinating that whole
section on accountability and trust and
how
people contact ministers because quasi
quattang said really clearly there
in relation to boris johnson texting
senior business figures both men have
said
it was in a special circumstance in the
pandemic he said
that they've done nothing wrong that
people are trying to contact
ministers all the time and then he went
on to say to you
that people often contact him on his own
personal phone
and i think while it's talking about a
smaller issue in this case boris johnson
mr dyson green sill david cameron this
is a much
wider issue about access and trust and
who
has a hotline to government ministers
and that's something that quasi quotang
really carefully didn't address there he
talked about specifics
but he wouldn't talk in general and it's
an issue that's going to come up again
and again because the heart of it
is trust and transparency and that's
something that labour have accused the
government of not doing properly
but now as you say johnny mercer a
conservative mp former minister
is saying the same thing and this issue
is not going to go away
and i wouldn't be surprised if we see a
much bigger investigation into how it
works how lobbying works
and how government decisions are made in
the months to come which is but it's
hugely difficult when we look at just
the basic technology of all of this
we've just about all got mobile phones
we've all got other people's numbers
i mean you wonder whether this is going
to lead to to people having to
to move to completely different numbers
if they get elected
i don't think this is about people
having phone numbers and mobile phones
in contact with each other i think
that's always going to happen it's
always happened in politics even when we
didn't have mobile phones people would
have had
you know personal addresses to write to
or different contacts i mean that's the
nature of politics it's the world that
we all live in
but what this is about is that business
leaders having the ear of the prime
minister being able to text him
not just the prime minister but we've
talked about david cameron boris johnson
other ministers too
being able to get quick decisions made
that puts them in a much more
advantageous position
than many small businesses around the
country who are also struggling
also have questions and face financial
ruin actually because of this pandemic
and it's that that's the real issue it's
about how government works best for
businesses and whether it's fair
that big companies get decisions made
much quicker
by very senior people than smaller
companies do and that's something that
boris johnson himself when he came into
government
said he wanted to change and highlight
he promised that he would be there
for the working man and woman across the
country and he knew that he had borrowed
votes in red wall seats particularly
from other voters
and that he was going to earn their
trust and that's why this this issue for
the conservatives
is a really tricky one okay kate thank
you
we'll sort of come this morning planning
for a world beyond the pandemic we'll
talk to the chair of the house of lords
covered committee
aaron s lame fox about their new report
on embracing
a hybrid world that's at a quarter to
eight
at five past eight we'll talk to one of
the chief political strategists behind
the landmark
paris climate agreement ahead of the
climate summit at the white house today
and how likely are foreign holidays this
summer well at 20 past eight
i'll talk to the spanish tourism
minister to find out if
covid's certificates may be the answer
now on tuesday derek shauvin became the
first white policeman ever to be
convicted of killing a black citizen
in the state of minnesota now despite
the conviction
there remains concerns about
institutional racism across the united
states
one of the key witnesses in the trial
christopher martin has told sky news
that even in prison
the system favors a white murderer over
african-american lives
he was talking to our u.s correspondent
sally lockwood who reports now from
minneapolis
when george floyd bought cigarettes with
a fake twenty dollar bill
it triggered the wretched sequence of
events that led to the end of his life
the teenager who served him felt too
scared to work at the store
after his death but being a key witness
in the trial
brought christopher martin a sense of
relief
that probably felt the best for me to
let everything out and get it off my
chest and tell the world what really
happened
i thought it was very beneficial for
getting justice for george and his
family
so that was very satisfying after the
police were called
christopher martin was captured on cctv
with his hands on his head
as he watched george floyd's arrest
unfold
something he talked about on the witness
stand
what was going through your mind during
that time period uh disbelief
thank you okay why guilt
um if i would have just not taken the
bill
this could have been avoided you say you
felt guilt
how did it feel hearing the words guilty
for derek shaven
very good very satisfying and relieving
it took a load off my back in a lot of
ways
so i would say relieving
handcuffed in court derek shovin was
taken into custody
safely and with dignity something he
hadn't afforded
to george floyd for christopher equality
is still a long way off it just shows
again this is what we have to deal with
inequality he gets a
nice good trial and he gets to be
protected in prison for
however long but obviously that's not
the same for an african-american
i believe that once they put their badge
on they believe that they're
um better or higher up than
other people and civilians and so that
gives them
the right quote-unquote to treat people
however they want to
it's sickening and there needs to be
change immediately
uh derek being guilty that's one step
but um there's a lot of areas that still
needs
needs work and you also have to live
with the memories of what happened
do you think that's something you're
going to carry with you forever
absolutely that's something i'll carry
to my grave
it'll get easier every day
we're looking at some of the other
headlines for you today and india has
reported the world's largest single
day number of daily covid19 infections
more than 314 000 number people were
confirmed as
having caught the virus across the
country 16 million confirmed cases
almost two hundred thousand deaths
hospitals have reported oxygen shortages
amid the increase in cases
as well as a new variant being
identified days ago india was placed on
the uk government's red list of
countries
for entering the uk that actually
doesn't come into force until four
o'clock tomorrow morning
pervasive racism was behind a failure to
fully commemorate potentially
hundreds of thousands of predominantly
black and asian veterans who died
fighting
for the british empire that's according
to the commonwealth wargraves commission
who's apologized after it found that
more than a hundred and ten
thousand individuals were not formally
remembered in the same way
as their white counterparts the defense
secretary will make a full statement
on the investigation's findings later on
today
the family of danto wright a black man
killed by police in minneapolis
preparing for his funeral today
just days after derrick chauvin's guilty
verdict for the killing of george floyd
hundreds gathered at a local church last
night for a public viewing for the 20
year old
with family and friends weeping before
his casket
which was covered in red roses
now while this year's awards season has
been scaled down because of the pandemic
there are plans for the return of crowds
at the brit awards
four thousand fans are set to attend the
event next month without social
distancing
or masks but proof of a negative test
will be required it's all part of a
government trial which is giving hope to
venues across the uk
who hope to open their doors to larger
audiences again pretty soon
claire gregory reports
it feels like a lifetime ago at last
year's brit awards billy eilish unveiled
her bomb
theme
[Music]
[Applause]
but no time to die still hasn't made it
into cinemas
and hundreds of venues across the
country have stood empty
but that will change in may when 4 000
music fans attend
this year's brits they won't have to be
socially distanced
uh they won't have to wear a mask the
whole point is to actually do it in the
most normal way possible
but obviously to kind of test that as
well to see
how well these events can be staged
safely
it's one of a number of government pilot
events to get audiences back on seats in
a safe return for the live music
industry
which was one of the first to close with
even the biggest names
out of work from a purely personal level
i've never spent so much time at home
i know since 1983 was the last time i
spent this length of time
in one place and it's been wonderful in
many ways but
professionally it's a disaster
[Music]
artists have campaigned for grassroots
venues which many fear are being
forgotten
we don't really feel that the data and
evidence that might be taken
from this event uh is directly
applicable to grassroots music venues i
don't think it will help
the exchange in bristol or the hundred
club or the
holodelphi to reopen grassroots venues
are desperate for a government pilot on
a smaller scale than an awards ceremony
without this it's hard to imagine
audiences back inside by the end of june
claire gregory sky news
okay let's see what the weather's got in
store for you today morning joe
good morning to you yeah it's absolutely
glorious out there plenty of sunshine
around not just today but for the next
few days
high pressure in charge but just because
we've got sunshine through the day
doesn't mean to say that the nights
won't be a little on the chilly side
let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you yes the
high pressure is going to stay with us
over the next few days so staying mostly
fine
right the way through until the end of
the weekend by which time we'll start to
see
a little bit of patchy rain working its
way southwards so this morning like i
say loads and loads of sunshine around
it's a beautiful start to the day
but it is cold many parts saw
temperatures below freezing
widely minus two or below and i think we
saw minus five in one or two places
so a widespread frost to start off with
but plenty of sunshine a little bit of
mist and fog over parts of ireland too
but that will clear
and through the course of the day very
little in the way of cloud
it may see a little bit of thin high
cloud over northern parts of scotland
but elsewhere
virtually nothing so temperatures rising
14 to 16 degrees celsius quite widely
and we could see 18 even 19 degrees
celsius
over parts of northern ireland western
parts of scotland that's a 66 degrees
fahrenheit
that'll feel very pleasant in light
winds but we are starting to see the
winds picking up a little bit through
the channel
and across devon and cornwall so it will
feel a little bit colder here
and temperatures a little bit lower on
the east coast too
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you now will justice for
george floyd bring about
change to the united states i'll talk to
a former u.s federal officer
in just a couple of minutes
[Music]
[Music]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist
metal are you trying to run me over to
phillip no
go away sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart
of america's opioid crisis
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget christchurch has been changed
forever by what happened
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
boris johnson has insisted he's done
nothing wrong by offering to help relax
rules to secure as many ventilators as
possible
at the height of the pandemic private
texts show the prime minister told
james dyson he would fix a restriction
so the businessman could help make
ventilators for the nhs but it's raised
questions over the ease of government
access for big business
well the business secretary quasi
quattang defended the prime minister's
actions
saying this was the sort of thing that
happened all the time
in reality people are contacting
ministers contacting mps all the time
business people
are contacting mps all the time
constituents also
contact me uh on my phone and i think
that uh
in the modern democracy it's very good
that people actually have direct
can have direct access uh to ministers
and people who are taking responsibility
in this particular instance i don't
think they're separated
i think it's very important to realize
that we were acting in
unprecedented circumstances the prime
minister had to make decisions at very
high speed
and there was a crisis people were dying
well we also spoke about today's major
climate summit between world leaders
including some of the presidents and
prime ministers of the planet's worst
polluters
china has said it won't reach net zero
until
2060 a decade after most other nations
across the world well uh let's talk to
our asia correspondent who's in
beijing for us this morning i mean they
they have at least agreed
you know a net zero target but it's
still a long way off
it is a long way off and right now china
is the world's biggest polluter in terms
of total volume of emissions the us
is the world's biggest polluter per
capita so the news that
president xi jinping will be attending
president obama
biden's virtual summit should be welcome
if there's going to be any action on
climate change it is going to require
china and the u.s uh making these sorts
of commitments this sort of cooperation
and we did see john kerry the u.s
special envoy for climate arrive in
china for talks with his counterparts so
that does seem promising
but i think rather than cooperation
really what we're going to see is
competition between
china and the us at that summit uh xi
jinping didn't meet john kerry himself
instead he met virtually again with the
leaders of france and germany announced
some new goals
uh showing that this is very much their
agenda they don't want to be bossed
around by the u.s and that's something
that xi jinping also tried to do
after president donald trump pulled the
us out of the paris climate gourds xi
jinping took that man
and said we're going to lead the way on
climate change and it liked the
adulation the acclaim it got for that
whether that has translated into
emissions is another thing so i think
we will see this rivalry the us and
china competing on so many fronts
economically diplomatically militarily
and climate might be added to that
unlike those other sectors though this
could be really good news for the
environment if these two
uh superpowers really are trying to
outdo each other on climate that can
only be good news for the planet
okay tom thank you or just a reminder
about the daily climate show
which you can see later on today a
special half hour edition can be seen
tonight at half six and a half nine
and you can catch up on the go with our
climate cast
now the conviction of derek chauvin
could be a landmark moment in america
but the question will now turn to
whether the verdict
could trigger change in the country
president biden said it was a start
clearly more needs to be done well
let's talk to former uh law enforcement
executive
michael horace he joined the police
after himself suffering at
an attack by the officer an officer it's
good to see you
this morning look can i ask first and
foremost about your own experience
because
to be attacked by a police officer in
your youth
to then move into the police force
is i even today would be a bit
surprising
well good morning and thanks for having
me while it may be surprising
i've always felt that it was my
obligation and duty to become a part of
the solution
and not be a part of the problem so i
had to really honor
and privileged to serve for 27 years and
serve my community
in a very substantial way look what what
do you think the
the the fallout may be because we've
we've seen
obviously a lot of of killing of
of black youths in particular over the
last few years which have caused
outrage but none more so than than
george floyd and with this
pretty historic verdict on tuesday do
you think this
could be a catalyst for change
we're very hopeful that it'll do several
things number one it'll cause that
critical change to policing
culture in the united states as you know
many times
culture each strategy for lunch and even
the greatest leaders
have not been able to promulgate change
in these police departments
number two it will send a clear and
visible message to law enforcement
officers
that these egregious acts are
unacceptable
and will not be tolerated under the arm
of the law
and number three hopefully it'll start
to erode
that lack of confidence that the public
has gotten in law enforcement
and restore trust and accountability to
communities particularly
communities of color can i ask if you
thought mr chauvin was
was going to get convicted of this
because a lot of the
initial reaction we've got was this huge
sense of relief and
people thinking look perhaps yet again
this wouldn't happen
right well i thought that he should have
been convicted but my
learned and earned life experience has
taught me that
should and would and could are three
different things
and repeatedly we've seen similar cases
result in a different outcome yeah i
mean
a lot of people referring back to
trayvon martin
well as trayvon martin there was rodney
king and a whole slew of others
so this although we hoped and
anticipated and prayed
we there was still some reticence to say
that the system
yet again would not work in the favor of
the citizens
how much distrust is there
at the moment between particularly the
black community
and the police force but as you're a
prime example of the you know there are
there are
plenty of african-americans in the
police force so
you know what level does that trust
start to build up
well we're hoping that this might be a
step in the right direction
but the mistrust and lack of trust is
very substantial
what you saw yesterday was a sire relief
from millions of people
that have been beat down and beat up by
a system that says
that your lives don't matter now people
have been asserted that at least in this
case
not only george ford's life but other
lives matter as well
what about the the reaction then from
from president biden i mean the fact he
has been
you know so outspoken of this the fact
this is being led from the very top
from the white house is that going to
make a difference
well we'd like to think that leadership
matters and leadership should matter
so we're hopefully that if nothing else
he can start those critical
conversations
and get that government in intact to the
point we can now act
and move protest to policy
it's a difficult situation isn't it for
for police forces who
you know understandably you're going to
feel a bit under fire
but potentially from from some of this
now there's clearly going to be some
anger towards the police and that's
absolutely
understandable how how do the how does
the
separate police forces actually get to
start working within the community again
in a more effective manner so
show your human side a bit more
well i think you hit it on the you
nailed it we have to get back to
community policing
we have to start to erode that ship of
trust
that's been eroded and we have to get
back to being uh guardians and not
warriors
there are those situations where we need
that worry or mindset
ensure that we go home at night but the
day-to-day
duties and responsibilities of police
officers are to interact with the
community to make people feel
safe and show them that they're there in
their best interests
that has been eroded and just like any
other relationship in our lives
we're going to have to work really hard
to get that back and i think that
now is the time to do it if at all if
ever i mean
i guess one of the keys to this is going
to be having a police force which
which properly represents the community
it's serving
well you know recruitment and hiring are
two critical elements
of community policing we need to hire
people that look like the communities
and represent the communities that they
serve we need to ensure that we bet
people properly so we don't get people
in the profession
that don't deserve the honor of serving
and then
when we identify people that shouldn't
be there we need to get them out of
this profession as soon as possible
matthew is good to talk to you this
morning thank you
now still to come on breakfast this
morning planning for a world
beyond the pandemic is hybrid working
here to stay we'll find out in a couple
of minutes
there are things we all take for granted
as the rivers and tides flow
the sun will rise the wind will blow
and the earth will spin but are we now
spiraling
into a climate crisis which cannot be
avoided no one can predict
the impact that it's going to have close
to the peak here
this is really the moment it's true
expected to be hit very hard
indeed what can be done to reverse the
spiral
the daily climate show on sky news will
look for the answers
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines
[Music]
that's what's left of the north tunnel
this is a show of strength
shrapnel from that explosion this is
nearly a week after the tag it's a
complete scene of devastation
to the heart of the stories that shape
our world
we're not sure about the road we're
going to try and find a way out
we help you understand the world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast but wherever you are welcome to
the safety ridge
holiday podcast for the ones who want to
know more welcome to the all-out
politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that if we make
small changes to our lives we can reduce
air pollution by
loads but how much exactly loads
higher pressure dominates the weather
over the next few days
so that's going to bring us fine days
but also rather frosty nights
but the sunshine's picking up
temperatures really quite well we're
looking widely at 14 to 16 degrees
celsius today
with potentially a 17 or 18 for parts of
ireland
or western parts of scotland in terms of
air pollution
generally levels are going to be low but
there is just a chance of seeing one or
two pockets
picking up to medium over the next few
days
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
now the pandemic has forced many of us
into
new ways of working but is it all here
to stay well a report commissioned by
the house of lords kovid 19 committee
focusing on a new style of living after
the pandemic has published its first
series of papers outlining some benefits
including working from home
and a possible move towards what they
call hybrid
health care well let's talk to the chair
of the house of lords kovac 19 committee
baroness lame fox good to see you this
morning
um right it's it's trying to get a
saying that every cloud has a silver
lining i guess
hybrid working how how is that going to
be
implementable for most people
well i think most people have tried to
live
in a hybrid world over the last year
already you know not all jobs clearly
can be done from home
but many many millions of people have
been asked to work from home
where possible and what we're calling
for is to make sure that
if this is um something that people want
to do and if this is something perhaps
in the future we are called to it to do
again
that it's fair and that people have
access to the right equipment
that they have more rights perhaps than
they've had in their last year
rights to have a break rights to have um
more physical activity if they're
sitting down all day
you know different style of contract
with their employer than perhaps
we've had in the past because of the new
way that we're going to be working
but we're also calling for the other
side of this you know lots of people
being asked to
do their services only online you might
be a doctor and you've suddenly had to
do doctor's appointments
clearly schools have had to do a huge
amount and so
we want to make sure that the people who
are providing the services as well have
got
high quality digital skills and are able
to build the best possible services for
the people that are using them i mean i
know a lot of companies are
sort of seeing some benefits of of
hybrid working but it
isn't there a perhaps a concern that
this may have an impact on what is going
on in the high streets in towns and city
centers you've got fewer people going in
it's going to affect
supply chains and cafes and restaurants
and all the rest of it
yes you're absolutely right but we would
uh argue that
this is happening you know what's
happened in the last year is in some
ways an acceleration of
trends that were going to happen over
the next five to ten years anyway
and we've sort of leapfrog leapfrogged
forward into the future
but what we need to do is make sure that
in this leapfrog we haven't left too
many people behind
that we've given people the necessary
skills for the jobs of the future
the high street is going to look
different over the next decade
and we want to make sure that it looks
different to the benefit of the maximum
number of people
with great green spaces for people to
gather together
with amazing places for people to
perhaps learn new skills for people to
use
um technology in different locations so
in a way these things were beginning to
happen already and the last year has
fast forwarded us through so many
different trends we want to make sure
that they really are
equitable and that give the opportunity
to the maximum number of people
can i um ask about this the safeguarding
of people though i mean
like a lot of people i work from home
last year i did six months presenting
the program from home and it started off
being great
i could get up later i could have the
cat on my knee when i was interviewing
people like you is
it was very nice by the end of it i was
fed up and by the end of it
yeah by the end of it i just needed to
get back to the office so
how do we safeguard people and their
their their mental health really
it's a really important question our
committee is tasked with looking at
uh economic and social well-being and a
huge part of that clearly is mental
health
and you know the it's easiest for all of
us you know i've got a nice office i'm
sitting here talking to you but
imagine if you've got children at home
you don't have the equipment for them to
be able to home school
you've got a job where you need to be on
line for most of the day you may not
have a fast connection
these are very big stresses in people's
lives so you know
while it's easy to paint some positives
out of all of this the fundamentals of
our report show the massive inequalities
that people face and the enormous
stresses
not just for the haves and the have-nots
but also for people that were juggling
so many things
and we need to make sure that we're
giving people flexibility but we're also
being
very aware of their mental health and
people's mental health coming out of all
of this
so these are enormous questions and it's
very um
important that we don't paint a picture
that this was all upside and this was
all positive for people
it really wasn't and the pandemic has
shown the enormous inequalities in our
country and if you look at it through
the lens of
this rapid acceleration through digital
it's just even more pronounced
what about the the hybrid healthcare
side that i know you've been looking at
because
again from my personal experience my gp
was doing so much online it was
you know what it was really quick it was
really easy it was
really efficient and since things have
eased off
they've pulled all that back they've
pulled all that offline and it's back to
the old system where it's
slow and stodgy if you like how do we
encourage people to actually
use these skills when it comes to
healthcare that we've we've gained over
the last year
you kind of summed up the whole report
for us kind of brilliantly
you know some of the benefits are
immense being able to see a doctor in
more quick times be able to do it more
on your own flexible schedule and for
the for the doctor as well to not have
to bring people in necessarily to the
surgery
when perhaps they could just do a quick
video consultation
but you know there hasn't been a
strategy at the heart of government or
within the healthcare system
for this new blended approach and as you
say much of this is good much of this
has been beneficial to patients
but much is unclear as well and much
also very difficult for people who don't
have the same access to technology
so what we're calling for is for the
very heart of government led by the
prime minister
to think about what this new world what
this hybrid world where
some things will be done better online
but some will absolutely not and people
will need that face-to-face support and
connection offline
what it means and how it filters through
the whole of the government system
this is a big change and we're saying
it's super urgent because as you quite
rightly say
some of these challenges that we faced
we overcame and actually there were some
benefits to them
but for other people that was not the
case at all and we need to have some
much clearer joined up thinking at the
heart of government led by the prime
minister
to make sure that we take the best of
what's happened over the last year
but don't leave people behind and
certainly don't create terrible services
for people going forward
great to talk to you this morning thank
you
thanks okay let's get a quick check on
the weather with joe